all right so
what should we start out with uh
managing money in ltr uh do you guys
have like a blanket policy that you
use when it comes to something like that
i mean some of you in our
ltrs and our rollo's married some of you
guys are not so
i have many policies all right i am i'm
here just to hear what aaron says
okay so so let's start with the captain
himself aaron cleary so what is your
so what are your many many policies when
it comes to managing money in a marriage
or a ltr
the the many but i'd say probably the
most important one um
is making sure financially you are two
separate
legal entities and depending on where
you are in which country your state or
province what laws are
but also in terms of even removing all
that when it comes to
the actual functional relationship
financially
you have your money i have my money and
the two shall not twain
and what i really like about that is it
it establishes sovereignty
it establishes that you are a person and
i am a person
and that both people have to be
independent and no one else could
parasite off of the other
and once you start co-mingling funds and
i'm not saying you know your girl get
her don't get her a dress or don't buy
her something nice or maybe if she you
know
she wants to put down payment on the
house if you're going to get paid back
okay i could see it you know like
helping out
and being kind but girls have i've seen
it even
and i've been in several long-term
relationships they have this natural
default programming they go to where
it's like okay i'm the wife now i'm
being taken care of
no no no no no that is long ago even the
good girls that i'm sure none of us
committed to bad women
even the good girls will default to this
it's like i'm sorry
that is no longer financially possible
given the tax rates we face
the legal risk we face and and just
generally we both have to work now
you have to be your own woman now the
feminists have made it clear you
you want to be strong independent the
majority and democracy have spoken
and that forces an economic reality upon
both men and women where you both have
to be independent
and this contradiction no matter how uh
genetically programmed they might go to
slip or default back into
a dependent housewife type of mode in
whatever capacities
you have to be vigilant on that and so
even occasionally
like i'll pay uh for for my girlfriend's
dinner
uh in part because she also does work
for me i can write some of these things
off
but then every once in a while i'm like
hey thanks for getting that dear and
she'll look
oh and then she discovers her wallet and
she pulls out the credit card it's got
cobwebs on it and she found
and she's like how do these work again
i'm like well you give it to the nice
waiter guy and he
and then they're like oh i see and so
that i would say of
of the many that would be the main one
is you must keep your finances separate
so you keep yourself sovereign i would
agree with 100
of that there's there's nothing that i
disagree with i find it interesting that
whenever aaron talks about finances i
i have a hard time disagreeing with
something that he says
um everything else you disagree with
though right well yeah because i mean
you're not right about everything of
course
you